on the crypto front
um where like how do y'all feel about
crypto now because obviously a lot of
[__] has crashed
I've lost some money for sure not as
much but I lost money in 2017 pretty
badly because this [__] guy convinced
me to buy all this Ripple
yeah whatever and you didn't sell it
when you had all that money anyway
um but how do you guys feel about like
kind of like obviously because I kind of
look at crypto as like similar to like
the.com.com bubble that happened
um you know there was a lot of
low hanging fruit scam [__] going on but
I do feel like like the technology of
blockchain is something that
will probably be around and be you know
a utility for a long time to come but
what do you how do y'all feel about it
I think crypto is here the idea of
blockchain technology is very real it
has very real use cases and it's
actually being used right now
um the functionality and the purpose of
crypto still has to kind of be worked
out I feel like
um it's not something that is really
necessary right now like they still have
to kind of figure out because even if
you look at Bitcoin which is the most
popular cryptocurrency most people are
looking at that as a store of value
they're not looking at it the word
currency is a little misleading because
it's not being used as currency it's not
it's being important they're parking
their money yeah it's more of an
investment or you're just hoarding it
right hoping that it goes up in value
nobody's going to the store and pulling
out their Bitcoin card and shopping at
Target yeah and and it's in order for
currency to be used it has to be some
level of stability like I can't get my
hair cut today for twenty dollars and
then go back tomorrow and it's 50 and
then the next week is ten dollars like
doesn't make sense and that's how
that's how volatile cryptocurrency is so
right now we're in a winter for crypto
but historically crypto has always had
these Cycles where it's gone up and then
it's going down then it's going up and
it's going down so if history repeats
itself it will go up again but I think
it's important to to Really you know if
you're going to invest in cryptocurrency
use coins that
um have a strong chance of surviving so
ethereum
Bitcoin you said xrp different things in
that Nation where it's like a lot of
these meme coins like the Dogecoin and a
bunch of these other coins it was just
like a get rich quick scheme it wasn't
really based around any fundamentals it
wasn't based around any use case it was
just based around all right let's just
pump this coin yeah everybody had a coin
my friend who's sitting to the right of
me
yeah he thought it was a great idea to
invest in a coin that Willie D from the
Ghetto Boys was spearheading
the Willie D Coin and I was like what
was the clinical
and I was like is he from Houston I was
like I was like
Willie D Willie D a legend yeah for sure
shout out to them yeah well you lost all
your money yeah I think I mean you said
it best I think when you compared it to
the.com it makes it's a good analogy
yeah right but the key is right when
the.com bubble started you had aols
United excite.com
right but you also have Yahoo and you're
at Amazon it's about figuring out which
one is going to have the long-term
sustainability and as we get further
inside the space of cryptocurrency and
they'll be better and more improved
coins obviously he spoke about the two
most prevalent ones but you know Google
comes to that 2006. or YouTube comes in
2006 right so there's an evolution
that'll happen and it'll become more of
a use case scenario and it'll be more
improved but it's not going anywhere
right we've seen it since 2012. you
mentioned 2017. we felt that pain too
right we have money in the space and
didn't take it out I should have sold
them
but it's one of those things if we're
looking at it as a short-term investment
or a long-term investment and so we tend
to look at things in the long term right
so it's a space that we'll be in and
we're going to stay in right